uh good afternoon and thank you for
joining us again this afternoon
i am pleased to be joined today by covet
19 response director caleb cage
to my left and ms julia peek to my right
who is leading our contact tracing
efforts from the nevada department of
health and human services
as i mentioned last week and again this
past monday
nevada continues to be impacted by an
increasing burden of covet 19
in our communities i know nevadans have
been watching the numbers
and the increases in our state and
across the country
just as i have we are seeing covid
trends surging nationwide
and as the start we and as we start to
see some alarming trends in the state of
nevada
i want to take the time to provide more
in-depth updates on what we are seeing
right now in nevada
i asked caleb and julia to be here with
me to take a deeper look at our trends
and how it compares what we've seen in
the last eight months
and what we maybe expect to see if we
don't take action
to change the course of this trajectory
at this time i'll turn it over to caleb
and julia to take a deeper look
at the data that we are dealing with
caleb thank you governor and as a
point of personal privilege i'd like to
just say uh thank you
for the opportunity to be here i'm very
proud of
the work we've done and grateful for uh
your leadership here
over the last eight months during this
very challenging time
my remarks will coincide with the
presentation that for those of you in
the room
will be able to see up here on this wall
ms beak and i are glad to be here to
provide you
with this update and for all nevadans as
well
i want to quickly begin with an overview
of the national status
we've seen a seven day average in new
cases
states we've we've seen the seven day
average of new cases in the united
states exceed
70 000 for the first time and
more than half of the states are
reporting case numbers at new
record levels in the last month the
number of hospitalizations from covet 19
in the united states
climbed about 45 percent hospitals
nationwide are beginning to express
concerns about being able to provide
sufficient care
to patients nationwide trends are
indicating
that new cases are being driven by
relatively small gatherings
of families and friends where folks are
more likely to let their guards down
that's the coveted fatigue
that the governor has been talking about
and it is setting in
as the governor mentioned on monday
vaccines are in development but we're
not sure
when they will be available to the wider
public
as this data from the white house report
shows cases per 100
000 three months ago two months ago
and one month a month ago as you can see
three months ago
we had a few areas of cons concern
but about a month ago nevada was doing
pretty well
this graphic shows the data from last
week as you can see we're seeing
alarming trends
in new cases in nevada and across the
united states
in this week's white house situation
report for nevada we are again
in the red zone where the 22nd highest
state reporting more than a hundred new
cases
per 100 000 residents 71 percent of our
counties have moderate or high levels of
community transition
transmission according to the white
house and 24
of our counties are deemed in the red
zone
that's based on the total number of
known cases and
high and high test positivity rates that
suggests that there may be
even more cases than currently estimated
or found through testing and contact
tracing
that means without a doubt that we have
community spread in the state of nevada
here's our latest reporting on this
slide here's our latest reporting from
the department of health and human
services
this is a snapshot of the data we posted
earlier today
there were 571 new cases identified
yesterday
of those 322 or 56.4 percent
we're in clark county 189 or 33.1
percent
or in washoe county and 60 cases or 10.5
percent
were in the remainder of the state there
were 10
new reported deaths 7 248
reported tests and the 14-day test
positivity rate is at 10.1 percent
for the most recent seven day period
cases are growing at a rate of 0.8
percent
or 774 new cases per day
for some additional context when the
governor had a press conference last
tuesday
just eight days ago we were seeing 666
new
cases a day we are trending upward
as you can see on this slide uh here's
our testing data
as a reminder we are working to meet a
cdc goal of testing a minimum
of two percent of nevada's population
per month
which would break down to about 2200
tests per day
which we are meeting
in terms of cases from testing we find
cases of covet 19 as you all know
as the governor mentioned last week the
number of newly diagnosed cases of
covenanting began to increase
at the end of september we're seeing an
infection rate above
one which means the outbreak will
continue to spread
unless there are changes in our behavior
to help mitigate
that spread the 14-day test positivity
rate has climbed
to almost 10 percent regarding
hospitalizations
as we have seen in nevada and across the
country with previous waves or
surges an increase in cases almost
always
leads to an increase in hospitalization
two or three weeks later you can see
that here
we saw an uptick tick in cases in july
and you can see hospitalizations climb
in the state in august
now for mortality and unfortunately we
know from our experience that after
cases surge
surges come from hospitalizations and
then unfortunately
deaths can occur again you can see that
phenomenon here
from the summer after cases and
hospitalizations increased
you can see the court you can see
corresponding an increase in deaths
for some individuals it's all tied
together
we we do know that our hospitals have
learned a lot in the last eight months
about caring for and treating
covet 19 but that's not through luck
that's through the hard work of our
medical professionals
each and every day to provide the
highest levels of care
we don't want to end up like other
states across the nation who are on the
brink of implementing crisis standards
of care measures
that means hospitals are rationing their
resources and making evaluations of
patients who have a better chance of
survival
and that's where they are dedicating
their resources crisis standards of care
means gurney's in hallways
it means zero visitors for loved ones it
means nurses
and professionals uh struggling to
to find enough ppe to use nevada is not
actively
implementing crisis standards of care
and we want to ensure
that it stays that way i'm going to turn
it over to miss peak for a few minutes
to talk about the status of our disease
investigation
and talk about what we are seeing in
counties in nevada at this time
thank you caleb at this time nevada has
found about 25
of the covid19 cases through contact
tracing
that means there are positive cases out
there we are not catching through
contact tracing
which is an indicator of community
spread that's part of the reason we
implemented and have been encouraging
nevadans to download and use the covid
trace
app it helps supplement our traditional
disease investigation efforts
at this time we have surge staffing in
place to help our contact tracing
efforts
but those levels would drop down when
the coronavirus relief funds expire at
the end of the year
we do have grant money through the
department of health and human services
that will supplement these efforts but
we will be losing a good amount of staff
income the end of the year
on this next slide we look at county
data i wanted to take a minute to break
down some of that data and trends we are
seeing by the counties
some of you may be familiar with this
graphic back in july we
began looking at data from individual
counties and using three metrics to
measure whether counties have an
increased risk of transmission of coved
19
if counties meet two of the three
measures they are considered at risk
we look at the average number of tests
per day how many cases per 100 000
residents
and the test positivity rate this week
as the governor mentioned on monday
eight of the 17 counties are flagged for
having an elevated
risk of transmission washoe county has
an elevated risk of transmission
and has been for the last five weeks
lyon county
has been in an elevated risk for three
weeks in a row
clark alco and lincoln counties have
been flagged for two weeks in a row
and this week carson city humboldt and
nye counties were added to the list
we look at and update this data daily
and we do see some fluctuation
especially among our rural counties
of coming on and off the list at this
point i'm going to turn the presentation
back
over to governor scissok thank you
thank you caleb and julia for that
thorough presentation i hope you all
were able to follow along
i asked caleb and julia to lay out some
of our data so i could talk about the
great balancing act of 2020
that i am working on every single day to
achieve
in nevada we don't mean to scare
everyone with the data trends we're
presenting
but we have an obligation to have an
honest conversation with nevadans about
where we are
and what will happen if we don't take
this seriously
the public needs to understand that if
we don't step up together
and follow all public health measures
hard decisions
and trade-offs lie ahead the pandemic
has been
framed as a false choice shut it all
down
or do nothing but we know that's not the
case
we know that doesn't have to be our
reality
we know we can't afford it we can
continue doing our best to balance the
health and safety of nevadans
with the need to protect our economy
keep people employed
provide an education to our kids and
more
i promise that i am doing everything i
can to manage this balancing act
and that balancing act in nevada is
perhaps the toughest
in than any other state as many nevadans
know
we had to cut over 25 percent of our
annual budget last time we shut down
that translates to real services the
state provides
to nevadans that was a devastating cut
and i'm doing everything i can to try to
avoid having to do that
again earlier today i met with education
and health professionals
because i want more kids to get
in-person learning in a safe
and responsible way i am so proud of our
superintendents and education leaders
for their commitment to safety
we're making a lot of progress and look
forward to providing more updates
soon i'm also planning meetings with
economic and business leaders
and health officials too that's because
i don't want businesses to go under
i don't want people to lose their jobs
and i want to mitigate covet 19
as much as we can to help people keep
safe and stay healthy
that's part of the reason why i've
empowered local communities from the
start
to take additional mitigation measures
if their community is experiencing a
surge
that's why we created the county tracker
that julia talked about
it's why we created a task force chaired
by caleb to take targeted approaches
with counties that are experiencing
surges
as many of you know the covet 19 task
force has an emergency meeting
planned for tomorrow with washoe county
as washer county has been listed as
having an elevated risk
for the last five weeks
my expectation is that community leaders
will come with a robust plan
and if that includes tougher mitigation
measures i will completely
have their back i think caleb can talk a
little bit more about how tomorrow's
meeting will be set
up and who has been invited from washoe
county
thank you governor as the governor
mentioned after watching the situation
unfold in washoe county and after
previous task force meetings with some
officials
we've asked officials from across the
county to come together
and provide a comprehensive and
coordinated plan to help slow the spread
in washoe the people we've asked to
include
we've asked to join us include the
washoe county school district
superintendent
a representative from the university of
nevada reno washoe county health
district
washoe county the city of reno and the
city of sparks
i'm confident we'll be able to have a
productive conversation
meeting a productive meeting with all of
the stakeholders to truly evaluate
what we are seeing and to come to a
consensus on what steps
are next for the county thank you
governor
thank you caleb so here it is nevadans
here's my call to action to each and
every one of you today
you've heard it from me you've heard it
from our kovit 19 response director
and our public health officials we must
remain
vigilant in the fight against covet 19.
wear your mask properly that means
completely over your nose and mouth
not on your chin not hanging off your
ear and certainly not in your pocket
practice social distancing wash your
hands
use disinfect the hand sanitizer that's
made available
avoid large crowds make sure your social
distancing especially if you are indoors
be mindful of your interaction with
others
get a test if you have been exposed to
someone who may have kova 19
get your flu shot before we take
questions from the media
today i wanted to go over two other
important topics
social service first i want to thank i
want to talk about the nevada resilience
project
we know people are hurting and this has
been a difficult year
i want to remind all nevadans that
mental and emotional health resources
are available the nevada resilience
project
nrp for short launched earlier this year
and has resilience ambassadors located
with our trusted community service
providers
all across the state the goal is to
strengthen our state
and project focus on promotion
prevention and early intervention
we know that people are feeling more
anxiety and depressions but in nevada we
have built a plan
to help our citizens develop their
resiliency
learn coping mechanisms and find support
our resilience ambassadors are working
on the community level with existing
agencies
to provide coping strategies and stress
management to the communities
that they are a part of a new website
for the project has launched and i
encourage you to check it out at
nevadaresilienceproject.com
social support services i'd also like to
share some very valuable information
about housing resources available within
our state
there are currently federal eviction
protections in place from the cdc that
cover those who qualify
this is an opt-in program so tenants
must fill out a declaration form
provided
by the cdc if you need help filling out
the form or you think your landlord
is inappropriately trying to evict you
you can see help from your local legal
aid provider
more information on where to find this
form and how to fill it out are
available at the websites on the
slideshow
if you're fearing eviction there's help
available
you can apply for rental assistance here
at housing.nv.gov
and clark county just launched their own
new and improved portal
to apply for assistance you can find
that on the clark county
website as many nevadans know
this year there was new legislation
passed during the second special
legislative session
that allowed the nevada supreme court to
stand up a new mediation program
so landlords and tenants could resolve
their disputes themselves
instead of arguing in a court thereby
reducing the number of people in the
courthouse
during the covet 19 pandemic
it is extremely important for tenants to
file their answers and opt
into mediation to try to solve these
disputes
so please know that help is out there
that there are resources available for
nevadans who may need it
a few more things i want to add there is
an app
available the coford race on your phone
i encourage
everyone to put it on your phone
it's free it works it's effective
secondly we have after today two more
days of early voting
i encourage everyone to get out and
exercise their right to vote
whether they vote at an early voting
site whether they drop their ballot off
at a drop box
or whether they vote in person next
tuesday
third please get your flu shots
we need to do everything we can to make
sure that we do not overwhelm our
emergency rooms with flu
patients this year so please use this
opportunity to get your flu shots
thank you everybody for tuning in and
now we'll be happy to take a few
questions
governor hi welcome back
um
okay i didn't watch the president i hope
that he wore a mask
if he had an event i rather doubt that
he did and i would have hoped that he
would have gotten into a discussion
about how much we need another stimulus
package coming from the federal
government
in an organized plan neither of which
we've seen
but i don't have any comment about his i
don't know what the comments
specifically were
so
well if he means a club that i'm a
democrat i'm a part of that i'm a
nevadan if i'm part of that club that
he's talking about i don't know what
club he's talking about i mean
sometimes he gets talking about things
and i can't follow exactly where he's
going
but those are the clubs that i'd be a
member of if that's what he's talking
about but
i don't have anybody's ballots i've
never seen or found any ballots in a
garbage can and i
think sometimes this is just
exaggerations
i thought the cdc more term went later i
thought it went till the end of the year
there's any rollback of the cdc
moratorium
or it's narrowed in any way by any
rulings in court yeah well right now i'm
not looking that frankly i mean the
supreme court has got the uh
our mediation program in place i'm
hopeful that that will work
for most people we'll have to follow
along and see that goes and see if
there's any problem
before we make any changes to our
directives let's go to the next question
and uh
if we could try to do one question at a
time please hi governor
hey what's up bill how are you i'm fine
how are you good so
sticking on the theme of a politics vice
president pence will be in reno
airport tomorrow at a rally the venue
has signed an agreement with the airport
to limit the audience to 250.
that seems improbable i was wondering if
you think that's also the case and
well a fine of a couple thousand dollars
is that really enough of a disincentive
for for something like that well
hopefully the vice president coming to
town as a guest
uh in the state of nevada he will follow
the rules
he'll wear a mask he will practice
social distancing
and he'll abide by our guidelines for
the volume of the crowd the capacity
and the social distancing if the airport
and or operator
or uh landlord of that facility
choose to not follow those guidelines
there are authorities that will
you know take appropriate actions but i
would hope
that the bigger guideline and obviously
sometimes these
dollar fines don't make an effect on
them uh
i would hope that knowing that he's
putting the health
and safety of three million nevadans at
risk
by what could be inappropriate behavior
would be enough of an incentive
to have him follow those and not give
the impression that he doesn't care
about the residents of the state of
nevada do you think that
that some of the sorry bill i just want
to make sure mike's on to the folks
listening can hear is it up okay
do you think that that some of the
comments that are made
when the republican uh the head of the
ticket and the vice president come here
that's directed at the state
is that just a gin up a kind of a
dispute with you
i don't know what their intention is if
they want to gin up a dispute with me i
mean i hear this regularly i see it on
social media i try not to follow it my
kids
sometimes bring to my attention my
mother will see that stuff and tell me
i am interested in protecting the health
and well-being
of all of our residents i'm interested
in doing what we can to control this
pandemic and at the same time
open up our economy and i wish that they
would be interested in the same thing
i've argued for eight months for a
national plan
to distribute you know tests and vex uh
vaccines in the future and ppe and
whatnot to this date it has not come
and they can say it has as much as they
want but it hasn't come
and whatever they say it rolls off my
back
i am continuing to fight for the health
and safety of everybody in the state of
nevada and to get our economy back on
track
thank you thanks phil we'll go to sam
next
hi caleb would there have been more
counties flagged if we hadn't switched
how we calculate test positivity to the
testing counter method
well there i thought you were going to
have something else sam would there have
been more counties
flagged if we had if we had gone
had not gone to the test encounter
method well it seems like those
changed the positivity rates somewhat
substantially was there any thought
about
changing the metrics to follow that
change
uh that's a so as you know at our so
two parts to the answer one is um we
at a recent task force meeting we
reduced
the total number of tests that a county
needed to meet per 100 000
from 150 to 100 because of some concerns
that had been mentioned
by especially some of our more rural
communities and so we did adjust that
in order to meet their needs but the
testing encounter uh
decision was really made in order to
incorporate
the the appropriate number of tests
and to make sure we were de-duplicating
nationally in fact
we just got off of a call with johns
hopkins university
uh where they were commending nevada for
being one of the very few states
to transition to testing encounters
instead of overall tests
which was which was a really positive
thing for us i have not done an analysis
yet
to determine whether or not the change
would have resulted in a difference
um but i know our state biostatistician
could provide that very quickly
thank you sam and julia do you mind if i
add just a little bit on that so um
just looking at the data from last week
potentially one more county could have
been on
um based on a seven percent positivity
i'll let you know that tomorrow at the
task force there are changes related to
which counties will be flagged
um so encourage people to watch that
i'll just add just a little more
specific
specifics about um encounters one of the
things that we saw is as
as different types of tests hit the
market we wanted to ensure that we're
not double counting tests so if an
individual goes in and gets two
specimens collected one
is provided in a point-of-care test and
then one is sent to the lab
it didn't make sense to count that as
two separate tests it would appear to be
two separate individuals so we thought
testing encounter was just a better
methodology governor
it seems like the great balancing act is
somewhat a departure from
your prior messaging about following the
science at least in messaging has your
perspective on balance change at all
throughout the course of the pandemic
not really i'm learning as we go through
this i think when everyone
uh would admit if they were being
totally candid with themselves eight
nine months ago
we never thought that we would be here
today at the first almost of november
still in this situation you cannot keep
the economy shut down
forever and it's my hope that we
continue to
and people say open things up everything
is open except for one school district
in southern nevada
most things are open right now currently
now uh what we need to do
is to have people make the choice as i
said at the meeting on monday
if you want to go watch your grandson or
your granddaughter play basketball
wear your mask if you want to be able to
go to a concert or a football game
wear your mask if you want to help
create jobs
in the state of nevada so people can
support themselves wear your mask and
social distance
it's up to us to determine the direction
that we're going to go in
thank you may i add to that governor um
so i'd say we we absolutely are
continuing to
um to follow the science uh in these
decision-making processes uh
just last week um dr fauci um from the
from the national for the federal
government talked about
the need to continue to make sure that
opportunities to participate in the
economy participate in
education and so on are absolutely
essential
and that we need to we do know from
science and from experience as the
governor said
we do know exactly what it's going to
take
in order to stop the spread of this
disease this virus
and uh if we can implement that
collectively then we can continue to
move forward
uh with the with the economy open and
and otherwise
we will take the last three questions
that are up there mr cage i know going
into tomorrow with washoe county uh you
do a lot of analyzation
uh coming into tomorrow do you have any
uh idea or some
comments on what things you may have
kept them in the
high risk high risk classification for
the last five weeks
thank you if i this is caleb cage i if i
understand the question
correctly we've had a number of uh
conversations with the health officer
the county manager
and others within washoe county a number
of them several of them just today in
fact
uh regarding that very question and
as they have pointed out a number of
times in those conversations there's
there's no um there's no smoking gun
source there's no
uh employer there's no one organization
or or one
uh activity that's that's leading to
this that what they're seeing
is generalized community spread within
washoe county right now
now that means a number of things first
it means
we can excuse me we can as individuals
as
as a resident of washoe county my family
and i can take measures
uh to wear a mask to um to make sure
we're social distancing to do all the
things that the governor talked about
um and uh and i'm and i'm very much
looking forward to
hearing their plan their collective plan
and proposal tomorrow when we
when we meet in the afternoon uh do you
believe
that in this case coming upon this and
governors can go to you as well
that restrictions are then more
restrictions are coming for washoe
county can you tell that to the
residents or or
still leaving things up in the air you
asking me that question yes
i know that the elected officials in
washington county care about those
residents as much as i do
uh we made it clear at the beginning we
gave them authority and they had
authority to
ask to loosen things up or to have some
more stringent regulations in
in place five weeks is a long time to be
on that list
and i am confident that they will come
forward uh with a plan
to help reduce these positivities moving
forward they'll come up with something
that'll work
so you do believe more restrictions are
coming i believe that they will come up
with a plan whatever that might be
to uh make sure that we can somewhat
reduce this
spread of the disease yeah thank you
again that task force meeting is
tomorrow at 1 00 p.m
i think you may have just answered my
question but your expectation is in that
meeting in washoe county with
the school district and the university
and the
local officials you expect them to come
up with a plan
tomorrow i certainly do how will that be
announced will it be announced
individually by those entities will it
be announced for you
or well i'll leave that to caleb and
julia they're going to handle the
meeting tomorrow but
i would uh assume that they will come
and give presentations and say we're
going to do a b
c d that we hope will help reduce the
spread but i don't know caleb
you're going to yes governor that's
exactly right and i know they're they're
actually meeting right now
and among them various jurisdictions to
finalize that plan
uh and uh and we look forward to getting
that later this evening
is there an approval process that uh
they have to i mean you have to clear
the plan or so according to the road to
recovery
uh framework that we put together
earlier this year they'll present that
to the task force
uh which is made up of uh a number of
entities at the state and local level
we will either approve the plan
we will modify the plan or we will deny
the plan
uh tomorrow at that meeting okay thank
you yes sir
thanks so much question i think zach
thanks for taking the question guys
there's been a repeated
narrative at the last couple debates
from president trump and also campaigns
here locally that
we're on the mend things are wrapping up
the virus seems to be
in a good direction you the medical
professionals here in the state of
nevada four residents that are watching
these debates
attending these rallies are we on the
mend
as you're the medical leaders here is
this a a narrative that is true
from the eyes of science before we let
the medical professionals go and i want
them to follow up
we are not rounding the corner i don't
care who says it
we are not rounding the corner you can
see from the slides
our cases are going up anyone that says
of the contrary
is just not telling the truth dominant
anyone who says a contra
contrary is lying they're trying to
intentionally deceive people
and have them let their guard down we
cannot let that happen
we need to be more vigilant than ever to
step up everything that we did
the choice is ours as i said you want to
go to your kids football game
or you want to go with your buddies and
play basketball we can do those things
if everybody would just
follow the regulations the protocols
that we've put in place
if you don't want to follow them we're
not going to be able to do more things
but listening to somebody with their
hyperbole or their philosophical ideas
or frankly their lies
isn't going to change the fact that
across this country
the spread of covid the cases are
increasing
you can look at any show and see that
that's the case somebody telling you
it's not
so doesn't make it not so so i'll leave
that to caleb and julia
julie would you like to go ahead or you
want me to okay i couldn't agree with
the governor more
um we are as i said in my remarks that
we are experiencing a
seven day average nationally of over 70
70 000
cases our situation here in the state of
nevada parallels that
uh from a national that from a local
perspective as well
um and as we laid out in in our remarks
when we see cases
we know that within two to three weeks
we're going to see hospitalization
and within two to three weeks after that
we're going to see deaths
so that is that is the trajectory for a
typical
for for a number of the covet positive
patients here in the state
what i'd add to that is that narrative
is
exactly that it's only a narrative it
does not reflect the truth of the
reality that we're experiencing in this
country or around the world at this time
and i would say it's that narrative is
deeply disrespectful to our health care
workers who are on the front lines
dealing with this every day
and who want to go home and see their
partner significant others and their
children
to our our teachers who are trying to
make sure that they're having
meaningful opportunities to educate
their children and to everybody else
who's working extremely hard to keep
this economy open
agree with both of those comments i'd
say that in public health we're
incorporating covid
into our forever response there won't be
an end to covid
hopefully vaccine will get it to levels
um that we can control
uh the best way i could describe it is
that kovit is truly
a controlled burn in our community and
if we can keep it at levels where our
hospital capacity is healthy where we
can case investigate and contract
contact trace all the cases and people
isolate and quarantine
it's going to be like any other
infectious disease that public health
has been responding to for forever
at the point the cases grow too quickly
it becomes a wildfire and as you can
expect then we have to prioritize
what cases get investigated and contact
trace and so in public health we are
trying our best to
ensure that it stays a controlled burden
that we can handle it but that's
individual responsibility to ensure that
they help us
um and so so i do think it's a very um
destructive narrative to say that we've
rounded the corner because for us were
in this for the long run let me give you
the anecdotal we just built
a stadium in southern nevada that's
going to be home to the game for the
fremont canon on saturday
that stadium seats 65 000 people
more people every day in the united
states
every day than the capacity of that
stadium
are contracting this disease seventy
thousand people a day
i talk to my fellow governors my
colleagues they have to look at
restricting
rationing care in some states that's how
overwhelmed
hospitals are becoming they have to look
at maybe transporting patients out of
state
because there's no more room in their
hospitals and if anybody thinks that
that
means that we've got a handle on this or
it's going to go away in a few days
they're dreaming or they are lying to
the american people it's that simple
and i'm not going to allow that in the
state of nevada we're going to do
everything we can
to protect all of our residents and at
the same time
protect our economy so with that thank
you thank you for your time
great thank you everyone for coming out
and have a great nevada day